[Music]
chuck
gotta get this off my chest like now
okay um
hopefully it's not like any chest hair
[Laughter]
no it's not i'm not particularly hairy
anyway so that's not a thing
uh all right so when people say
they want to go into space i want to go
what do they typically mean by that
i mean i'm going to be an astronaut i'm
going to be i'm going into space man i'm
going
up there i'm going there up there and
generally they mean they want to go into
orbit
right most anyone who has ever been in
space
they don't mean that they want to go to
space man
well well okay if that's the case do you
know how many
people have left low earth orbit
well first of all you are going to have
to
define low earth orbit for me okay sorry
okay
because i'll say i'll say it another way
all right the apollo astronauts
okay okay that left earth right
to go to the moon all right okay and
that's
that's space okay wait a minute so there
was apollo
10 11 12 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17. so eight missions
left earth to go to the moon not all of
them landed right as famously
apollo 13 didn't and apollo 10
was just a dry run for apollo 11. but
those are the only people
who have ever left earth for a
destination
that's cool every other astronaut
hundreds of them are called astronauts
and we still say
they went into space and what that means
is
they went into low earth orbit oh that's
just
awful and so low earth orbit is
in practice with you know where the
space station is it's about a couple
hundred miles up
so so if so the distance
from earth's surface to the space
station is less than the distance from
new york city
to washington dc oh oh god
why are you depressing me like i'm just
trying to i'm just trying to
be honest about this is awful okay
so when people say to me you want to go
into space
and because somebody's got some orbital
tourist thing and i'm thinking
to me space is the large-scale structure
of the universe thank you
not boldly going where hundreds have
gone before
driving around the block as low earth
orbit
indicates okay so yeah you can drive
to earth orbit in you know three or four
hours
oh right if the road were pointing
straight up
so so so nasa
and others i'm not implicating nasa
uniquely in this
when they say we are going into space
that's what they mean
okay now there's a functional definition
of space
damn so space x should be no it gets
worse they simply call it leo x
low earth orbit x uh yeah well actually
they've got
sites on mars and more power to them
okay all right
so i count that as space personally all
right
so there's a functional definition of
space if you want to ask
have you been to space whether or not
have you been in orbit
and that distance is the height above
earth's surface
where you've left enough of earth's
atmosphere behind you
that the atmosphere is no longer
scattering sunlight
and if it's no longer scattering
sunlight it means in broad daylight
your sky is dark right okay that makes
sense
that makes sense so there's a distance
for which that's it and they rounded the
numbers so it's a nice clean number it's
100 kilometers up
or about 62 miles okay
all right so if you if you do the
conversion so if you get to that
altitude whether or not you're in orbit
you go above the blue sky all right the
daytime blue sky
then that sky gets darker and darker and
there it is black
it is black a space it is so you can
have earth behind you
the blackness of space over to one side
and the brilliant sun
off to the other side welcome to space
baby
oh is that does that happen once you get
past the blue
once you get past the scattered sunlight
welcome to space girl
what's happening
[Laughter]
welcome if you look to the left you
might see a little something called the
moon the moon
okay check we'll sign you up for the
narrative
[Laughter]
all right that's and so i don't have a
problem with that
except that definition
depends on earth's atmosphere doesn't it
it does suppose earth's atmosphere were
half as thick as it is all right
now you're going 31 and 30. now you're
going
50 kilometers 31 miles up oh no
okay oh that's terrible now suppose it
was one fourth is thick
now you're going 25 kilometers and 15
miles up
all right now suppose it was one-tenth
this thickness then it's 10 miles up
and suppose we didn't have an atmosphere
at all
so then are you still in space just by
standing here on earth because under
those situ
in that circumstance you would look up
and you would no longer have a blue sky
that's why i personally am not calling
that space
wow because you're using earth's
atmosphere as a definition of space and
i'm not giving it to you
so the measuring stick cannot be the
atmosphere of the body upon which you
stand
should not be influenced
by your atmosphere that's correct right
i can't give that to you i'm sorry
i understand why you want to use that
rule
because if you're going to have a
tourist jaunt and you're not quite going
yet into orbit you want to get at least
that high so you can see the night sky
in broad daylight
i get that but i'm just going to say i
just went on a very high
a very high plane ride that's all i
would say wow
now let me just say this uh
because i happen to know
that you know a lot of astronauts
yes a lot oh did i say this to their
face no
and i was gonna say i gotta feel i'm
hoping
i'm just hoping that you haven't had
this conversation
with any of them
because they would be like as soon as
you leave they're like
man that guy's a real a-hole man i'm
telling you right now
but when i was growing up my brother
would imitate them
exactly damn because that is harsh
but i mean it makes sense when you think
i'm sorry i'm just saying if you want to
say let's go into space
take me somewhere that's all is that so
wrong is that so
so so the i i don't want the definition
of space to be contingent on how thick
your atmosphere is
so it's so is the space station space is
is that beyond that threshold
the space station is it beyond yeah
because even at that level there's still
a lot of atmospheric particles there's
just not enough of those particles to
make
the day sky blue with sky blue so
but that's too low to put anything in a
sustained orbit you go up to the space
station it's 200 250 miles
that's still getting atmospheric
particles hitting it
so every now and then the space station
has to be boosted back to its original
orbit
because the atmospheric particles are
decaying the orbit
so so yeah this is a
um it's it's outside of that
definitional
layer um but it's still low earth orbit
it's still leo low earth orbit and
i don't even want middle earth orbit or
or or geosynchronous orbit they're still
you're still kind of attached to earth
and
i don't i'm sorry as an astrophysicist
to me space is the large-scale structure
of the universe
so give me my warp drives and then i'll
be happy
all right listen um i i can't
find fault with anything you said it
it kind of makes sense especially the
destination part
which i think also inspires
progress i think where you're going yeah
destination inspires progress nobody's
right nobody says
pack a bag i'm going to the store
nobody does that or no one says watch me
drive around the block a hundred times
exactly
exactly nobody does that you know
grandpa are you gonna go anywhere
no no i'm just going around the block oh
let me tell you we're going for a drive
around the block yeah no
no nobody does that going to a
destination makes all the difference in
the world so i'm going to give you that
yeah
you got it all right we got to call it
quits there that was another star talk
explainer chuck good to have you
always a pleasure keep looking up
[Music]